let failure be your friend
there are going to be times
of course
where you're going to win a lot
a lot of things are going to go your way
and it's wonderful
to bask in that adulation and to feel
proud of your successes
but there are also going to be times the
satisfaction that those moments bring
nothing can compare to that those
victories will feed you for years to
come and help you stake a minute
when your tank is sometimes empty
winning is great it's fantastic i love
it i love being number one i love
winning
but it's the times when things go wrong
when you fall or fail
that you're actually gone going to learn
the most about yourself
you know
all those years on the oprah show 25
years we were the number one show for 25
years and that's because i lived with
the intention
to serve the audience the audience came
first every show i would sit with the
producers and say well i can't do that
because i can't find the truth of myself
in that show i have to have a thread of
truth to be able to hold on to so i knew
so well the audience i felt like i was
the audience the audience
was me
and i felt so connected
and then i ended that and started a new
network
and i flailed for a while
and i was really upset with myself
but i will tell you
that when i was able to shift the
paradigm to start to looking at wow what
i have instead of what i don't have what
i have instead of what i thought i'd
lost i was able to begin to turn things
around but it's those moments of being
of uncertainty it's the moments where
you know all of my mistakes show up on
the evening news you can make a mistake
i can tell if i've done something wrong
it's on the cnn crawl i can read about
it
but learning from the moments where
things weren't going so great
being able to get still
to connect with that which i know is god
the force the power greater than myself
and to come back
and realize that in order to move
forward you move forward by taking the
next right step you don't have to know
everything to do you don't have to know
all the steps to make just what is the
next
right move
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
billionaires think to get some success
advice from the top
enjoy
rule number two surround yourself with
great people with richard branson if
you're a business leader somebody's
watching this and wants to be richard
branson or sir richard branson what is
the key
um
surrounding yourself with great people
um
learning to delegate early on um not
trying to do everything yourself um
uh
you know making sure you've got the kind
of people that are praising the team
around them not criticizing the people
um
uh um and
uh and
you know
having people who are willing to um you
know to really innovate be bold and uh
create something which everybody who
works for the company can be really
proud of rule number three innovate with
jeff bezos you mentioned that you wanted
innovation to inspire this next
generation why is it important to you
why is it so important you personally to
make that happen
well i think you know i was very lucky
kid i was inspired by invention and
self-reliance from a number of different
people and from you know even
watching the apollo program as a little
boy and i think when little kids get
inspired you'd never know what might
happen
it's a big deal and everything about our
society
gets better over time i really do
believe that i'm an optimist you know
the myth of the good old days is usually
just that a myth
we have better medicine than we've ever
had before
everything you know all of that is
invention it's people figuring out
antibiotics it's figure people figuring
out new kinds of uh biomedicines
biotechnology
it's things that have been figured out
with the kind of communication that we
have the freedom of speech we have now
with the internet
there are so many things that are
getting better and a lot of that is
powered
by
uh invention
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four build a better
future with elon musk one of the things
i think that like quite important for
the future to be good and
obviously in order for the future to be
good we have to have sustainable energy
so we have to have sustainable
production and consumption of energy
so
uh that makes means making solar panels
low cost and
making electric cars appealing
and then
we want to become multi-planet species
and a space spring civilization says
rockets
and
and then there are some things that i
thought it'll affect the future but i'm
not sure
if it's good or bad
like ai
that survived me that one rule number
five do good with jack ma i'm a believer
i'm not technology person but i'm a
believer the technology
is great for human beings
and as a technical company
don't be evil it's not enough
you should be do good things for the
world do good things for the future
and believe in young people rule number
six follow your curiosity with mark
cuban michael jordan had the body he had
the temperament of a champion so he goes
into sports do you think they call that
bounded rationality instead of saying i
could be every possible thing in the
world you kind of limit it and say all
right i'm more of a math guy oh i'm more
of a people person and then you try to
find your destiny within that well i
think they go hand in hand right because
the type of person you are you know kind
of points to the things you're good at
are you 12 you're not gonna know are you
16 you're not going to know if you're 18
maybe if you have a
special talent yeah right you know you
can throw a baseball 100 miles an hour
you can sing and your voice is
incredible you know you're you know a
concert pianist you're a chess
grandmaster if you have a specific skill
set or talent that just immediately
propels you to the top yeah you want to
follow that yeah but i remember having a
list i still have it um when i graduated
from college i was getting ready to
graduate and all the different
industries that i thought i might want
to partake in when you find something
you're good at yeah go for it yeah and i
also also always say it's not about
passion
everybody's got passion for something
right don't follow your passions follow
your efforts because people say you know
i was passionate to play baseball i was
passionate to play basketball it doesn't
mean all of a sudden i was going to be
good enough yeah but i found myself
spending being really curious about
business being really curious about
technology and that curiosity is really
what drove me and i think particularly
if you're young today curiosity is great
always learning and trying to find new
things and being curious about new
things because that's what leads you to
that path trying to figure out in
advance yeah that's hard because you
don't know what you don't know and rule
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is get known
with grant cardone one of the key i run
a marketing agency and a lot of my
customers say well i spent one dollar
and i one pound and i only got one pound
back that's not success i need to spend
one pound and get six back what is
success in marketing
number one is to get known you shouldn't
advertise first you should get known
first
so if i spend a dollar in marketing or
branding i i don't need my dollar back
it's
when you have a toilet you buy a
business and you get a hey we should put
a bathroom in our business
how many of you have a bathroom at your
business
what's the roi on that
there's no roi on that
how many of you have an air conditioner
and a heater at your company
what's the roi i mean does that get you
customers the air conditioned sends you
customers
some things you need to do because
you're in business
when did you start making sense of not
getting known
there is nothing more important than
getting known
if you if you can't get known you can't
be in business if i don't know you i
will not do business with you if i don't
know this woman in red no matter what no
matter what no matter how good her
product is or what the price is i will
not do business with her regardless of
her ethics regardless of her honesty
regardless of her service if if we if we
don't know each other
we won't do business
so i would spend money on marketing
before i'd spend it on a toilet and air
conditioner
and climb online stand is just through
there and to the left
i mean i i would
and i i wouldn't expect i wouldn't
expect mark to get me a lead i would
expect mark to get me known
so that when people see my name they're
like i saw you do this thing
with
uh with grant cardone when he came
through wales that's how you lift your
brand
it's just a smarter thing to do today so
that when you advertise with him and you
see the name now you're like oh i
remember you from this and that and they
put the pieces together people buy from
people they know
not from people they trust
people do not buy the best product
either people buy the best known product
i love that you can't tell me this is
the best coffee in the world
it's the best known coffee in the world
the same thing i told myself the same
thing i tell everybody one you're 21 22
23 years old right you don't have to
figure it out right now
don't try
right you spend all this money
sorry
um
pain to learn
now it's your chance to get paid to
learn
you don't need the perfect job
you just need to go somewhere where
you'll learn
and start to be exposed to different
ideas and now it's not like you know
when when greg 40 years ago was
graduating
and me five years ago
you know it was like get a career
and you know the pressure was get a
career go work for ibm or general motors
and get a pension those days are gone
people can't even pay their pensions
anymore and so you're a free agent
and you're always going to be a free
agent on the market you guys are the
kevin durants and lebron james you know
where you're always out there and can go
find a better situation for yourself
do what's best for you what have you got
to lose like when i started my company
you know after i got fired by michael
umeki um
you know what was good how bad could it
be i would lose my motel sixth towel you
know
it was just like what have you got to
lose and yeah i understand there's
pressure from student loans and there's
a lot of conversations we can have there
right but you know you can get a job
that doesn't have to be perfect you can
learn at that job and you guys have the
pedigree you have the brains you have
the initiative to go out and try the
next job you know
you know the good news is the economy is
good enough that it may not be perfect
but you can go job to job don't look for
the perfect answer just look to get the
experience look to learn because all
these different exposures all the
different things you learn learning how
to learn
that's what's going to give you get you
excited and juicy for for something that
you love because once you find something
you love to do
that's when the magic happens
because when you when you're able to
find something you love to do then you
can start work focusing on how can i be
great at this
and like greg found out he was a great
networker i like to you know play with
technology and try to do things first
you know whatever it is that you find
about yourself then you can try to be
great at it and it's rare when people
quit things they're great at
you know and so trying those things so
that that's how i advise people don't
don't stress just go out and try
different things what keeps you so
unbelievably grounded amid all your
resounding success
i i feel like success just makes you
more of who you already
were i feel like money and success just
does that so
it's like it holds a magnifying glass up
to who you are people you know people
always ask me that and i'm like i don't
know who else to be i mean i am who i am
so the money the success
and um so i like to say if you were a
jerk before you got really successful
and a lot of money you you become a
bigger jerk usually and if you were
insecure you'll become more insecure if
you were nice you'd become nicer if you
were generous you'll become more
generous it's literally just
a magnifying glass the thing i think
that i did right from the beginning
and even
now in this moment uh now that my
circumstances are very different
is i've
i've always known
and this comes from i think my faith
deep down inside i've always known that
like what i'm called to do isn't about
me
and so
for me it's it's what's fueled me
in all the times
when it seemed like no one else believed
in me like i knew why i was doing this
um was so much bigger than myself and to
really shift culture and beauty and even
now
even just saying like oh my gosh
you started something in your living
room and someone pays you a billion
dollars for it like if i think about
that i can't even process it right i
can't even handle it because what
happens is i'll start thinking of like
oh but you know
i don't i didn't come from the right
family no one of my
neither my parents went to college all
those things that we tell ourselves
about why
we're not the person that has those kind
of things happening to us
um
and so so two things one i i often
remind myself that like anything that's
ever been created that's great or that's
a brand we all use now or a big business
like it was all created by somebody
really at the end of the day who's just
like you and me just like all of us
every single thing right so like why not
i'm not you why not yeah and then and
then the other thing is like when i
really start to um
kind of like get in my own head about it
because it is really
strange you see like oh yeah like all
those things like um
i i make it not about my i i know i
remind myself it's it's not about me
right so for my book for example i'm
donating 100 of the proceeds but like
like i the the book is to serve right
and like i i believe at the end of the
day that we get in life like what we
give you know what i mean along this
whole journey i've known it's bigger
than myself even now like i just i don't
know i believe that you know i'm called
to serve and and to
like i feel blessed to have accomplished
one of my biggest dreams but my my
biggest
my biggest driver now is helping other
women
um
and especially their entrepreneurs and
really other women like accomplish their
greatest dreams so how have you hired
your team uh and
what do you look for when you bring
people on
if you think about it
you know i started the company when i
was 19 right so
i can't institutionally believe that
experience is that important right or
else i would have a hard time
reconciling um you know myself right and
and and the company so you know we
invest in
in people who we think are just really
talented even if they haven't done that
thing before and you know that applies
to people who are fresh out of
university as well as
you know people like um you know the cfo
who took the company public had not
taken a company public before right and
a lot of his background was in um you
know production
development at genentech before so you
know just focus on really talented
people when you first launched in the
very beginning the features were sort of
profile with like a profile photo in
your name and who you are and also you
included things like what house you
lived in um what dorm you lived in um
and what courses you were taking
do you think it would have worked
without that would it have been enough
just to have profiles
you know it's a really interesting
question and we certainly since then
have evolved and wanted to make a more
general service so we've so we've
dropped some of those things
but i remember um there's this early
debate that dustin and i had where
we had to do some manual work for every
school that we that we released facebook
ad and um in order to do that we
basically went through and we parsed the
course catalogs of the schools to make
sure that the data was clean
and um and i remember having this debate
where dustin was like we could just
expand so much faster
or it would just be easier i mean we
were bound by server capacity but it
would be easier to launch new schools um
if we didn't have to have course
catalogs for for each school and we just
had this really long debate
about what quality meant for us and the
community that we wanted to establish
and and the culture of it and um you
know in retrospect you know maybe it
wouldn't have had a huge difference on
on how things played out but it
definitely kind of set this tone where
there's a lot of kind of clean data on
facebook you can rely on it it feels
like a college specific thing yeah which
was valuable early on for setting the
culture even though obviously since then
we've grown beyond that and you know i
mean i think you guys in the projects
that you work on you're gonna have a lot
of similar questions right i mean
there's the famous 80 20 rule where you
know you get 80 of the benefit by doing
20 of the work uh but
you can't just 80 20 everything right i
mean there have to be certain things
that you just are the best at right and
that you go way further than anyone else
had to establish this kind of quality
bar and have your product be the best
thing that's out there so you know
whether we had to do that one or had to
do something we had to do i think enough
of those things or else we just wouldn't
have been the best service out there
there's nothing that ai won't impact as
big as the um so bit having been around
a while i saw the impact of pcs then i
saw the impact of local area networks
then i saw the impact of wide area
networks then i saw the impact of the
internet then i saw the impact of mobile
then i saw the impact of wireless you
know now i'm seeing the impact of of
artificial intelligence and it dwarfs
any of those things and if i don't
understand how to apply it to my
businesses i mean i remember selling pcs
and software and walking in saying you
don't need to use that pen and paper on
on a you know on a notepad or a ledger
pad now we're going to give you a
spreadsheet and by the way here's a
here's a spreadsheet that costs 495 and
i had to pay to go get trained on how to
sell it which is crazy now when you
think about it but then we said okay now
you can play what if then we said you
can connect these pcs unless i
understood the technology how was i
going to explain it how was i going to
understand it unless i understand it now
how am i going to invest in it
you know then i got to go trust somebody
who says oh yeah i know ai and maybe
they do maybe they don't and it's really
easy just to have just to okay say you
figure it out that's just not my style
so you're building a base of knowledge
and then you think that at some point
it's going to pay dividends and trades
already has right i mean if you truly
believe a.i is going to change
everything how are you going to
understand what people are doing to
change everything unless you at least
have a foundational understanding of it
now i'm not going to build a million
layer neural network and try to change
the world and i'm not going to show you
i'm not going to write a research paper
and saying here's how why the lottery
ticket approach works and you can build
smaller neural networks with less data
and be more you know
resource efficient but i can read that
stuff and understand that when somebody
says okay we're building this project
and we need this size data set or this
size data set we need this amount of
resources i can ask questions and
understand the answers what is it about
selling the that you actually enjoy that
you think most people most people don't
enjoy selling so what is it about
selling that you actually well okay this
is the first thing i'm going to say if
you don't like selling
you should really take the time for
yourself to practice it and learn it
because all of life is sales i mean
whether you're an accountant whether
you're a stay-at-home mother and you're
trying to sell your kids on why they
need to go to bed at a certain time or
they need to do something that you need
them to do in an interview you have to
sell yourself i mean and so um i think
it's really important to be able to to
do that and and hardcore door-to-door
sales was incredible groundwork and laid
that laid the foundation for me to be
able to do spanx because when i started
spanx the first two years that i was
cold calling all the manufacturers in
north carolina i only heard one word
no yeah
i mean no no no and because i had
training and just knew i'm gonna keep
going till i get that yes that's the
reason that i was able to get through
that stage
you know i think that uh i think there
definitely are things that one can
iterate on but the the core thing is to
have a great product and then you can
always improve and and iterate on that
in all sorts of ways and i think you
know i think um even in in the tech
industry um
uh what's striking is how
um
weak on a quantitative basis so many of
the successful companies were it was
just they had a great product and then
years later they were able to optimize
it in all sorts of all sorts of ways
whereas if you're just trying to
optimize and you don't have a great
product
i think that that rarely works um i
think it's always worth asking you know
where you're going to go with this
business um and so i think we're always
focused on very short time horizons
because you have to you know figure out
a way to get through the next month the
next quarter
you know how do you get some customers
how do you how do you track but it's
it's always worth thinking ahead you
know five to ten years you know why will
this be a really valuable business in
five to ten years and um you know how's
the competitive landscape going to
develop how's technology going to
develop how's the world going to develop
um these are hard questions to answer
but i think i think i think i think the
the great entrepreneurs that i know
always have some perspective on it and
it might be wrong but it's just this is
what's going to happen and then it's
sort of well reasoned and and so you
have a you have a plan it and you know
it's uh when i when i was playing chess
uh you know in junior high school one of
the early lessons i learned was a bad
plan is still always better than no plan
at all right and so
you know have a plan you can always
change it but don't uh don't just
pretend that uh that you have no clue
about what's gonna happen and that
everything about the future is random if
you if you sort of say that everything's
random and out of your control that's
that's that's the way you set yourself
up for failure i think you should be
doing something you're passionate about
so the question is always
you know when i give my younger self
advice you know if would i still go to
stanford or i still go to stanford law
school
um possibly but i think a lot more about
why i was doing it was is it just uh you
know you know i was on this super tract
for myself i ended up at a big law firm
in new york
in my eighth grade junior high school
yearbook one of my friends wrote and i
know you're going to get into stanford
in four years i went to stanford four
years later went to stanford law school
ended up at a big law firm in new york
where on the outside everybody wanted to
get in on the inside everybody wanted to
get out
when i left after uh seven months and
three days
um
one of the one of the people down the
hall from me said it was you know really
reassuring to see that it was possible
to escape from alcatraz which you know
all you had to do was really just go out
the front door but um but so much of um
our identity gets wrapped up in the
competitions we win
and um
that um and when you compete
and i think a lot of the credentialing
resume building is this sort of
competition when you compete you do get
better at what you're competing at if
you take lots of sat test prep classes
you'll get a better score on the sat
um and when you compete you get better
at uh beating people on the narrow
things you need to beat them on but um
but you often it often comes at this
very high price of of losing sight of
what's uh what's truly valuable and
important and meaningful
which is well i think passion there's
well there's sort of all sorts of other
there are all sorts of things that that
could be that but but i think
um i think it often
the the i think it often ends up being
uh something that's a little bit off the
beaten path because uh so i think um you
know there's there's obviously financial
version where you get to be have a
monopoly like business
there's a the meaningful version i think
is always counterfactual where if you
weren't doing this
uh would you know it's great to be
working on problems where if you weren't
working on them nobody else would do
them you know if you're working at the
fourth online pet food company the 10th
in film solar panel company the 1000th
restaurant in philadelphia
there's a sense that if you weren't
doing it someone else would um you know
if you're working at uh
at something where
it's the only thing of its kind in the
world that's very meaningful if we
weren't if we and it could be for-profit
non-profit all sorts of context if we
weren't doing this this problem would
absolutely not be tackled i think that's
the kind of
that's what's that's what's meaningful
on an individual level i think it is
always uh it's always really good if if
there's something that you're incredibly
passionate about and um and just sort of
are fine to be intrinsically interesting
and and that that people pursue that um
and so the you know one of the
one of the the the resolutions i came up
with a number of years ago was to always
value substance over status substance
over prestige um
and you know if i sort of it was giving
my younger self advice on what to what
to do or how to how to think about um
your when's one's life i you know i
probably i think i you know um
i probably would still go to stanford um
you know
i might still go to law school
but i'd ask i'd ask sort of i'd ask a
lot more questions why why i was doing
these things and i think
i think if i was honest about it
too much of it was driven by
by prestige and status and not quite
enough about um really the substance of
uh of trying to learn things and you
know i had sort of this i sort of think
of it as this sort of crazy rolling
quarter life crisis and sort of
culminated in this uh in this you know
big new york law firm where you know
from the outside everybody wanted to get
in from the inside everybody wanted to
get out um you know um after i lasted
seven months and three days and after uh
um and uh when i when i when i left one
of the people down the hall said you
know it's so reassuring to see you leave
peter i had no idea it was possible to
escape from alcatraz which which again
uh and you know and again i and all you
had to do was go through the front door
but our identity um people's identities
get so wrapped up and um the things they
compete for that it was inconceivable
for people to actually do that and and
then the question was you know well how
had i ended up there why had i not
thought about that more and i think it
was
that i had taken too many of these
shortcuts of valuing sort of what was
prestigious what was conventional over
what i uh what i really wanted to do so
i think i think always substance over
status i know that one of the key things
one of the things that's made me
successful in my life
is making it a priority to control
my thoughts like what what am i thinking
about like literally putting discipline
in on
how i talk to myself
and so i don't want this to sound all
the cycle babble stuff it's not like
it's not like oh if you just stand in
the mirror and talk to yourself and say
positive things everything's gonna be
all right be careful what you say to
yourself okay
because if you're saying a thirty dollar
stake is a lot of money
or a four dollar toy is a lot of money
when your kid wants a four dollar toy
listen to what you're saying
that's a lot of money
dude four dollars is a lot of money okay
on my worst day four dollars has not
been a lot of money even though
okay i've been at periods in my life
where i didn't have four dollars
so i'm talking to you today about
how do you control
how do you
control how do you discipline
how do you start monitoring what you're
saying to yourself
i can't find the right girl can't find
the right guy there's no good guys left
in this town all men are pigs
women cheat on their men
marriage is hard
having kids is difficult
i don't want to pay taxes
you know
i can't help myself i can't stop
i can't trust myself i never do what i
say i procrastinate i'm an introvert
i'm broke i'm poor
so
look what are you saying to yourself all
the time the first thing i did was i
took a i took a little journal out and i
just wrote down all the negative things
i say to myself by the way i just gave
you the list
okay
i can't spend money
i can't save enough money i don't make
enough money okay i don't know how to
invest in the stock market i can't
invest in real estate i don't have time
to do this you know the time thing
people just kill themselves with the
time thing i don't have enough time i
don't have enough time i don't have
enough time guess what
oops
you don't have enough time you don't
have time you don't have money catch
yourself every time you say i don't have
time
say hey i create time
every time you say i don't have money
i create
money um or maybe just start just start
literally like talking to yourself that
hey i am a millionaire i am a
multi-millionaire i own
if you want to if you're in the
apartment game and you want to be in
apartments but you don't know anything
about apartments you can start literally
talking to yourself saying i am worth
uh uh or i own 100 units i did this for
years for years before i ever bought an
apartment i used to write down i own 20
apartments that earns 12 percent cash
flow
over and over i bet i better wrote this
down a thousand times i own 20
apartments my first deal was 38 units i
own 20 apartments or more
and and i write it in any little journal
any piece of paper any legal path every
time you say something negative write
down uh i need to lose weight
okay
that's good but you know if you're
running a race
you don't say i need to finish the race
you're like you're looking for that
you're you got to run right you got to
run you got to move you got to keep
moving your feet so i mean you can sit
there and say i got to finish this race
but the truth is if you need to lose
weight man just once you pick your
target weight
and start affirming
that i weigh 165 pounds
i weigh 165 pounds just switch it a
little bit right all you're trying to do
is discipline you're trying to move the
river
so if you're broke right now quit saying
i am broke
and start saying what you want where are
you going one part that i'm always um
very focused on sort of the structure of
these companies and how how well are
people aligned and so you can um
and uh making sure that people are you
know aligned properly not just that they
say i think this is sort of a very a
very legal kind of a framework to think
about what are people's incentives you
know are they going to be aligned or not
and i think you want to both have formal
alignment where you set the structure
right and you want to have
informal alignment where the people
would naturally try to work together
well in one one way or another um
and i think that somehow tends to get
obscured in all these other ways um you
know there's always a there's always a
there's always a
prehistory question i like to ask
founders of of companies which is um
how did you uh how did you
meet what's the prehistory of the
company before you got started um and i
find that to be really instructive a set
of questions to ask a bad answer is
something like you know we met a week
ago
at a social networking function at a
business networking function we decided
to start a company because we both
wanted to be entrepreneurs
you know that's like saying i married
the first person i met at the slot
machines in las vegas and you might hit
the jackpot but it's probably a really
bad idea um and a much better answer is
you know we've been talking about this
for a long time you know maybe
one of us is more on the tech side the
other one's more on the business side we
have these sort of complementary skills
and uh and so i think this question of
um alignment and structure is um is
incredibly important i say to the my
girls
all of the time that your real work
is to figure out
where your power base is
and to work on the alignment of your
personality your gifts that you have to
give with the real reason why you're
here that's that's the number one thing
you have to do
is to work on yourself and to fill your
self
up and keep your cup full keep yourself
full now i used to be afraid of that
i used to be afraid particularly from
people who say oh she said she's so full
of hassan
she's so close herself and now i embrace
it
i i consider it a compliment that i am
full
of myself
because you only when you're full i'm
full i'm overflowing my cup run is over
i have so much i have so much to offer
and so much to give and i am not afraid
of honoring myself you know it's
miraculous when you think about it
failure and invention are inseparable
twins
um you know it's everybody wants to
be inventive you know if you go talk to
corporate america or
any any institution actually uh
government agencies and so on innovation
is something to be proud of people like
invention
but the problem is they don't like
failure
and you cannot have invention without
failure um if you
to know where if you already know it's
going to work it's not an experiment
and only through experimentation can you
get real invention the most important
inventions come from trial and error
with lots of failure and and the failure
is critical
and it's also embarrassing and so that's
why people
in when we're kids
we always are doing trial and error and
we're never embarrassed you know if you
watch a little toddler and they will try
for hours to put a square peg in a round
hole and it never works but it doesn't
keep them from trying
and they try things like that and that's
how they learn
and uh and
and we all have that when we're little
and then as we get older somehow it's
not as cool
as you get older to fail and to fall
down it looks clumsy
and so we get in our grooves we have a
set of expertise and skills it's kind of
a comfort zone and you have to
constantly push yourself to say no i
don't care about failure in fact if you
know i say at amazon we have to grow the
size of our failures
as the size of our company grows we have
to make bigger and bigger failures
because otherwise none of our failures
will be needle movers and so i would see
it as a very bad sign
over the long run if amazon wasn't
making larger and larger failures and if
you do that all along the way
that is
going to protect you from ever having to
make
that big you know kind of hail mary bet
that you sometimes see
companies make right before they
fail and go out of existence
the most influential people in my life
were my grandparents
and i have a my mother had me when she
was 17 years old she raised me
with my grandparents help and she was
still in high school when she had me
that was not cool in albuquerque new
mexico in 1964.
but she did an incredible job but i was
lucky because i had not just her but i
had she re she married my father when i
was about four years old he has been a
huge influence in my life but my
grandmother and grandfather
were like second set of parents for me
and you learn different things from them
because they're at a different stage of
life and they know different things
they're calm about certain things
it was a huge gift to me my grandfather
was a
had a ranch in texas and i spent all my
summers there from like age 4 to 16 and
he was the most
self-reliant person he did all of his
own veterinary work all the things i
mean and to observe him
solve problems and figure out how to do
things with no tools and no resources
and you know very small amounts of money
it was
a huge education from an early age so
we're very like
one of the things that you i know people
who have
uh they don't have great
family situations
and sometimes they break that cycle and
they are the ones who pull out of it
those people are the ones i reserve my
highest admiration for and what about
steve jobs in those days what was your
relationship with him uh in the early
days and how did it change
well we were both there at the very
beginning
uh the apple one was a kit computer that
steve wozniak
designed and he worked with steve and
they came and offered it at various of
these computer club meetings and we went
to lots of computer club meetings so we
were sort of colleagues and pitching the
gospel of
uh personal computing we were kind of
competitors
the
the time we worked together most
intensely was after the ibm pc came out
steve had a group actually a small group
at apple that was doing the macintosh
and he came to us early on
and asked us if we'd commit resources we
actually put more people on the project
than apple did and did
the early application software that used
that mouse
graphics interface and so it was a huge
win both for microsoft and for apple
when the macintosh became so successful
i think it's also important to reason
from first principles rather than by
analogy so the normal way that we
conduct our lives is we we
we reason by analogy
it's we're doing this because
it's like something else that was done
or it's like what um other people are
doing me too type ideas
yeah it's like
yeah slide iterations yeah on on a theme
um
and and uh
and it's
because it's it's kind of mentally
easier to reason by analogy rather than
from first principles but by first
principles is kind of a physics way of
looking at the world
and what that really means is
you kind of boil things down to the most
fundamental truths
and and say okay what are we sure as
true or sure as possible is true
and then reason up from there
that takes a lot more mental energy
give me an example that like what's one
thing that you've done that on that you
feel has worked for you sure so
um somebody could say um in fact people
do uh that battery packs are really
expensive and that's just the way
they'll always be because that's the way
they've been in the past um you're like
well
no that's that's pretty dumb you know
because if if uh
if you apply that reasoning to
anything new that then you
you wouldn't be able to to ever
get to that new thing i had one habit
that uh i developed when i when i was uh
at college that was actually a very bad
habit which was
i like to show people that i didn't do
any work uh and that i didn't go to
classes and i didn't care and then at
the very last minute uh like two days
before the test i i'd get serious about
it and and people
people thought that was funny uh you
know that was my positioning the guy who
did nothing until the last minute then
when i went into business that was a
really bad habit
and it took me a couple years to get
over that nobody praised me because i i
would do things at the last minute and i
tried to reverse
to students i'd actually uh i didn't
think that highly of who were always
organized and had things done on time
i'm still working on it but
procrastination is not a good good habit
you don't have to hold yourself hostage
to who you used to be or anything you
ever used to do
because who has lived and hasn't made
mistakes when i think about my 20s and
what a foolish girl i was and how
i would
give over my power to men who
really didn't mean me well but now i
hold no grudges against them either
because i realize i'm the one who gave
over the power because i didn't know any
better and now that i know better i know
i don't have to do that again it's one
of the most powerful lessons any of us
can ever know i was very very bookish i
was reading all the time so i was either
reading
uh working my computer
reading comics playing dungeon dragons
that kind of
um
thing
understand hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy that wonderful book by douglas
adams that was a that was a key book for
you
what was it about that book that that
fired your imagination um yeah so
i guess when i was
in uh around 12 or 13 i had company
existential crisis and i was reading
various books
um
on trying to figure out the meaning of
life and well like what does it all mean
because
uh it starts seeming quite meaningless
and then
um
uh my we happen to have like some some
books by nietzsche and tropenhauer in
the house which you should not read at
age 14
is bad
it's really negative
um
so so but then i then i read the
hitchhiker's guide the galaxy was like
quite positive i think and
um
and it sort of highlighted the the an
important point which is that a lot of
times the question is harder than the
answer and if you can properly phrase
the question then the answer is the easy
part
and so
uh
the if to agree that we can um better uh
understand the universe then we better
know what questions to ask and
um then whatever the question is that
most approx approximates what's the
meaning of life
you know that that's that's the question
we could ultimately get closer to
understanding
um
and so i thought well to agree that we
can
expand the scope and scale of
consciousness and
give knowledge
um
human knowledge then that would be a
good thing wherever you're at in life
right now at this very moment
i believe everyone has a knowing inside
of them i don't think it matters if they
have a faith or no faith i don't think
about any of that i think everyone
universally has a knowing or a truth
inside uh and i think most people never
learn how to get still and hear it and
most people if they do get still and
hear it they're gonna know right now
live while they're listening to you and
me
are they in the right
job they're supposed to be in
or
is there is are they are they playing it
small
are they in the right relationship
or are they in it and dimming their own
light because of fear that maybe they'll
be alone we all have a knowing right
and you know what i'll say about the
idea of
giving up leveling up all of that
i think it's so important that um you
know in that moment where i had the and
again let me just say there's so much i
did wrong and i share all that stuff too
one of the things i did right was when i
had this this gut feeling as i'm sitting
there with this skin problem this gut
feeling oh you're supposed to figure out
how to how to create a beauty company
when i look back at this journey of
three years of constant rejection down
to under a thousand dollars in a bank
account
literally getting knocked down over and
over from all of these beauty retailers
that i put on a pedestal and i couldn't
understand why they were telling me i
wasn't the right fit for them
every time i would check in with my gut
right and maybe so many people out there
can relate to this because you you feel
like you're doing something you're
supposed to be doing but like for me
there was no proof around me that my
idea was right there was no traction in
my business there was nobody saying yeah
that's a great idea let me buy your
product and then i'm going to the beauty
retailers and they didn't believe in the
brand and everything around me was
saying you're wrong
and the easiest thing in life is to
confuse that
with the truth even after you had done
your thing there was still an eighth
course to make sure that yahoo itself
was on track do you know what that was
about yeah they were screwing everything
up you know i mean look they had they
had an opportunity to dominate um
streaming media they also owned at the
same time the patent to cost per click
yeah
right now google's entire business to
this day
is built around
pay-per-click rather they're not calling
pay-per-click yeah
so they had the entire patent for
pay-per-click
had they just said sorry google
you can't use it
there would be no google
instead they said yeah 133 million
dollars and give us some stock
they were just too nice
right which blinded them in a lot of
respects and i remember walking in with
a 32 million dollar sale saying okay
we're gonna do streaming we're gonna
sell all this company's content you know
it's worth 32 million dollars for us and
it's going to pre-up these other
potential competitors
and um
i forget if it's jerry or tim whoever
said no we don't work that way we don't
preempt competition we just leave it
open
i'm like okay it's time for me to go buy
a basketball team
that's they just they just didn't see
these things and i mean it's a lesson in
your businesses there's going to be
everybody's always trying to kick your
ass
and you have to figure out how to kick
your out your own ass first
seriously because if you're not brutally
honest with yourself and your own
business about what your frailties are
someone else is going to find them yahoo
didn't get that yahoo just thought you
know what we're just going to continue
moving forward and we'll just compete
with everybody else and you know there's
we have no other problems you know
people often ask me
what it takes to start a business what
is the key ingredient how did i how did
i start the business and how did we grow
to about 20 million dollar 20 million
dollars in sales so quickly
you know they all come up with some new
whiz-bang idea they're gonna invent the
the better mousetrap they're going to
come up with new software new hardware
and more often than not it seems like
they've spent their millions before they
they thought through their idea
but when we talk about new companies and
and growth and success there really is
only one common ingredient across any
type of business whether it's oil or
computers or software anything and that
key ingredient is customers
without customers whether you're
starting a business running a business
expanding a business you don't have a
business
there is no business customers are the
key ingredient get those profits
you gotta have the customers
you gotta have happy customers
that's the bottom line you know micro
solutions we've been we've been going
and growing and it's impossible not to
have growing pains
it's impossible not to make mistakes we
screw up all the time
and you know it doesn't bother me as
president if i have if i have an
employee who just didn't do something
right just made a mistake
it's good
because if you're not making mistakes
you're not trying hard enough you know
these things i'm saying they're not
unique they're not things that i just
thought up in some some miracle growth
you know things when i talk to people in
our company when i talk to people about
our company i never have a unique
thought
i can't remember i don't know that i
ever did i can't remember if i ever will
or don't expect ever to
there's no magic formulas to customer
service there's no magic formulas to
doing things right these these sayings
that you hear me say are things that
i've read elsewhere and just regurgitate
back
but how many people do them
you know we all know the golden rule
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you and that's nice you know but do
you do it
but even more importantly than the
golden rule what about the lovers rule
do on to others as you would love to
have them do unto you
that's what we try to stress the micro
solution that's what we try to use to
differentiate ourselves
not just to get by because everybody's
going to be nice
you know when you invite someone into
your house that is an acquaintance that
you like okay you're going to offer them
coffee
you're gonna offer them a doughnut and
that's really what you expect you know
if you went to their house because
you're just acquaintances but when you
leave the house
it was nice
if you go that's fine if you don't go
back fine that's the way customers look
at businesses if i go back fine if i
don't go back fine
you know they say that eighty percent of
the people who have a problem tell at
least ten people
only ten percent of the people who had a
good experience tell anybody
and it's the same way when you go to
visit an acquaintance
when people come to try to do business
with micro solutions i hope i pray and i
try to convey to each and every one of
our people
that we give them a reason
to want to come back
we give them a reason to do a good
morning rap to say okay let's do
business with micro solutions
you've got to really concentrate to do
unto others as you would love to have
them do unto you one time you know as
you know i went to indiana and
in dallas in the mid 90s you know when
when we had a good basketball team
we we literally would when we wanted to
listen to our big games like indiana
purdue go hoosiers um
we would call somebody in bloomington
who would put a radio next to a speaker
phone and dial us and we sit on the
other side listening over a speakerphone
drinking our beer and whipping it up or
doing whatever and the internet was just
starting to happen and now i'm a tech
geek and i'm like into all of it and
we're like
there's got to be a better way to do
this and so one of my buddies from
indiana todd wagner was like look we've
been thinking about this and i'm like no
i'll figure it out i'm a networking guy
now and so we
look for ways to
stream indiana basketball we called it
net casting back then over the brand new
internet and so i went out and bought a
packard bell 90 megahertz computer and
an isdn line
and downloaded all the software and i
said you know what i'm going to figure
it out
and lo and behold by
oh golly early 1995 we had figured out a
way to
we would we took these eight-hour vcrs
and connected it to a local radio
station record them we'd bring them back
go through this process called encoding
and put it up on this website we call it
audionet and then i'd go to any online
forum aol prodigy compuserve uunet
whatever it was or you use use use that
and i like if you're interested in
dallas sports at all because we haven't
gotten to indiana yet if you're
interested in dallas sports go to this
website audionet and back then you had a
dial modem you had to download the
software called tcpip and you had to
have software from your internet
provider which meant that so few people
knew how to use it we had no idea if it
would work or not
but all of a sudden audionet went from
10 people a day to 100 people to a
thousand people a day and as we added
radio stations they're getting calls
from all over the world from people who
are listening to their shows on demand
not even lined and then we worked with a
company that put together live software
company called zing and we made it live
and then everything changed and that's
really when streaming was born
and we just grew that and then in 1998
we got into video changed the name to
broadcast.com went public and it was the
biggest ipo in the history of the stock
market at the time
and then we sold it to yahoo if i sit
with a hundred dollars in my pocket
folks there is no economy
if you want to be economic you let money
flow it has to move you got people in
your company managers and executives
that are saving money they save their
money i'm like what are you doing dude
we're saving money how can you grow a
department if you go home and all you do
is save it
you know you open up somebody's freezer
and they got ice cream that's three
months old it's got this much left in
you you got you got diet coke that's
four days old it's got that much left in
it okay you got ziploc containers you
have whole cabinets of ziploc containers
and little plastic things where you in
case you had some leftover corn or peas
or potatoes you're like
don't throw it away
save that
save that that much pork chop maybe i'll
hit it tomorrow
see somebody put this back in here
that's probably elena doing that there's
no reason to put this back here it
reminds me of my mama
reminds me of when i grew up save
everything
it's a terrible product anyway why you
want to save it look at this she put two
apples in here don't put them back in
the refrigerator man
them or toss them
you're not going to go broke
or get rich
saving leftovers
what are you guys doing man you got it
in your closet that you ain't ever going
to wear it don't fit you it ain't fit
you in in years
right how many of you got stuff at your
house you could get rid of
you're trying to save stuff
dude how can you
how can you have new stuff come in when
you're holding on to stuff that you
don't even use
right so you have to use this it only
becomes valuable when it's used
now the question is what are you going
to use it on and the other question is
why don't you use it why are you so
compelled to hold on to it
what do y'all think that is
you don't know how to get more number
one reason i don't your mother did not
know how to get a new shirt
that's why she took so much put so much
time and energy in cleaning the shirt
you got a stain on
okay you broke a toy your parents got
upset with you can't believe you did
that
what did what man dude
toys are to be broken
that's what a good toy is for
right
right i lost a quarter when i was eight
years old and i would have thought i
would have thought my house
was gonna get torn apart because my dad
became so upset about the quarter you're
playing with money never play with money
what are you doing playing with money
and that that lesson pounded on me so
hard it kept me from making real money
for 20 years are there any leadership
principles
um
you know that that have contributed to
your success as a leader not as an
entrepreneur
leader does never fix the style
right some leaders good speaking some
leader never speak by actions
leader leadership doesn't have style
everybody can be a leader a good leader
should have a vision
the vision is that vision not
necessarily good because when i work in
the company
when everybody was disappointed i have
to tell them i have to see before the
other people see the opportunity
when everybody excited i have seen the
disaster
especially as a ceo of like a me in the
alibaba group
my job is to see the
problems of the future
[Music]
so
and kill the problems before the
disaster comes so a leader must have a
vision nobody's journey is seamless or
smooth we all stumble we all have
setbacks if things go wrong you hit a
dead end as you will
it's just life's way of saying
time to change course
so ask every failure this is what i do
every failure every crisis every
difficult time i say what is this here
to teach me
and as soon as you get the lesson
you get to move on if you really get the
lesson you pass and you don't have to
repeat the class if you don't get the
lesson it shows up wearing another pair
of pants
or skirt
to give you some remedial work
and what i found is that difficulties
come when you don't pay attention to
life's whisper
because life always whispers to you
first first and if you ignore the
whisper sooner or later you'll get a
scream
whatever you resist persists but if you
ask the right question not why is this
happening but what is this here to teach
me what is this here to teach me it puts
you in the place and space to get the
lesson you need my friend ed cartoli
uh who's written this wonderful book
uh called a new earth
it's all about letting the awareness of
who you are stimulate everything that
you do he puts it like this he says
don't react against a bad situation
merge with that situation instead and
the solution will arise from the
challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means acting with
responsibility
okay
many of you know that as president
hennessey said i started this school
in africa
and
i founded the school where i'm trying to
give south african girls a shot at a
future like yours stanford
and i spent five years making sure that
school would be as beautiful as the
students
i wanted every girl to feel her worth
reflected in her surroundings so i
checked every blueprint
i picked every pillow
i was looking at the grout in between
the bricks i knew every thread count of
the sheets i chose every girl from the
villages from nine provinces and yet
last fall i was faced with a crisis i'd
never anticipated i was told that one of
the dorm matrons was suspected of sexual
abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first i cried actually i sobbed for
about a half an hour
and then i said let's get to it that's
all you get is a half an hour you need
to focus on the now
what you need to do now so i contacted a
child trauma specialist i put together a
team of investigators i made sure the
girls had counseling and support
and gail and i got on a plane and flew
to south africa and the whole time i
kept asking that question
what is this here to teach me
and as difficult as that experience has
been
i got a lot of lessons
i understand now the mistakes i made
because i
had been paying attention to all of the
wrong things
i built that school from the outside in
when what really mattered was the inside
out
so it's a lesson that applies to all of
our lives as a whole what matters most
is what's inside what matters most is
the sense of
integrity of quality and beauty
i got that lesson and what i know is is
that the girls came away with something
too they've emerged from this more
resilient
and knowing that their voices
have power i feel like hustle is
the willingness to work really really
hard and then also your willingness to
get the job done like um kind of
navigating and
doing what it takes
and um
and so
i i yeah i've there's so much about my
journey where i was like i am not going
to let the outcome or my success be
contingent on other people as much as i
can control it help it navigate it i'm
going to
so
um
so yeah in the beginning especially
still now i mean obviously i'm hustling
i'm like at the at this where i am now
and i'm running around the airport
asking people to follow me on instagram
you know i just feel like it's innate in
me also to a degree um but
the uh in the beginning ex like there's
a few examples that come to mind you
mentioned that i paid my i called my
friends and asked them to go buy spanx
and i wrote everybody checks and sent
them a check
because i needed to drive momentum and i
had no money to advertise so i'm like
this product's going to sit on the shelf
so i needed to get
people to go in and buy it i also when i
went into the stores i realized very
quickly that my product was in the
sleepiest part of the department store
it was back in the corner and nobody was
going there so then i immediately
went to
target and i bought
um envelope dividing dividers that you
put on your home desk and i ran around
neiman marcus and put them at every
register and i put spanx in them and
then i walked away
and
neiman's has like impeccable visual
rules and regulations and um and i did
that because i had to get my product out
of the department and because i did that
women in shoes started buying spanx and
women in contemporary and and um those
decisions made such a big difference and
by the time somebody figured out that
nobody else had approved it because i
you know everybody thought somebody else
approved it
um
it was so successful that the head of
neiman's was like whatever this girl's
doing let her keep doing it how do you
deal with failure and what's your advice
to young entrepreneurs like me in this
case especially with regards to failure
and how to approach it yeah well if
if you fail you really do dust yourself
off and you know get right back in i
mean
you're going to fail at some things uh
uh
you're going to have some human
relationships that don't work out uh you
know
fairly significant number of people get
divorced i mean you know that's a very
big decision to have turn out badly but
uh
i think if you study
almost everybody and read read kay's
book you know personal history and
you'll everybody
fails at some things i mean you know
particularly
particularly when you're younger i mean
you know you do have less experience in
evaluating humans and you know and and
just knowing about whatever it may be
businesses
uh but you know it it is not fatal i
mean if you're healthy
and
you live in this particular living in
this country there's gonna be there's
gonna be an opportunity that comes along
uh uh i got turned down for the harvard
business school uh when i was when i got
out of the university of nebraska you
know and i remember you know i went to
chicago to get interviewed this is when
you traveled on the train and so i spent
10 hours going there and this fella
looked at me and about 10 minutes he
said you know forget it bell
and now i got to go back on the train 10
hours and think what am i going to tell
my dad
tell my dad i mean my dad always told me
i could do anything and everything now
i've just got just gotten turned down uh
you know but it turned out that one of
the best things ever happened to me
because then i went to columbia where
ben graham was it in fact
it probably even affected who i married
because i took a one-year course at
columbia and said two years at harvard
and she might have found some other guy
during that time
almost everything in my life
that looked like a failure has either
turned
well usually that's turned into a
success i mean it
it the world isn't over you know
if you have bad luck in health that
that's tough i mean that there's just no
there's just no getting away i've been
lucky on that but
but
the other kind of things if you're
healthy and you're bright and you know
you've got decades ahead of you you know
if
something goes wrong if you find
yourself working for the wrong employer
and they're you know they're doing
things you don't approve of or they're
not treating you fairly you know
the world isn't over yet you know you
just go out
and find somebody else during my
california springs and summers i spent
most of my days in the high sierras in
yosemite valley working
as a river guide
and a rock climbing instructor
i loved those jobs
but unfortunately they didn't pay that
well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley
i had learned a program in college
i didn't love programming
but was fun and i was good at it
and computer program programming gave me
the same kind of satisfaction
as solving math problems and playing
chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused teenager
at this point in my life
i thought i was making real progress on
my journey of self-discovery
i had found a cause
i had a couple of jobs that i loved and
one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife
was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing foolish things
she wanted me to work full time as a
computer programmer or go back to
college and finish my degree
we compromised
sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember was a sailing class
taught at berkeley marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair with the limitless
omnipotent pacific ocean
when my class was over i wanted to buy a
sailboat
my wife said
this was the single stupidest idea she
had ever heard in her entire life
she accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
she kicked me out
and then she divorced me
this was a pivotal moment in my life
[Applause]
my family was still mad at me for not
going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this time
i was not disappointed in myself
for failing to be
the person they thought i should be
their dreams
and my dreams were different
i would never confuse the two of them
again i remember distinctly i had this
one friend um who i i went and got pizza
with almost every night we did all our
computer science problem sets together
at harvard and
at the time i remember talking to him
about
how um i was working on this facebook
thing and i i thought it would be cool
for harvard and i really was excited
about it because i wanted to use it but
at the same time how i thought that over
time someone would definitely go build
this version of this for the world but
it wasn't gonna be us it was gonna be
you know microsoft or you know someone
who built software for hundreds of
millions of people it's like who we were
college students right we're not
qualified in any way to build this and
you know i think a lot of my takeaway
from that was that
we just kind of cared more than those
other companies about making it exist i
always tell people sometimes i get you
know we'll have a good um
quarterly conference call or something
and and wall street will like our
quarterly results and i'll get
people will stop me and say
congratulations on your quarter and i
say thank you but what i'm really
thinking is that quarter was baked three
years ago i right now i'm working on a
quarter that's going to reveal itself in
2021 sometime
and that's what you need to be doing you
need to be out sort of you know two or
three years in advance
and
if you are and then why do i need to
make 100 decisions today if i make like
three good decisions a day that's enough
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want seven more
amazing lessons from billionaires check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there it's certainly there
are times when
things don't go well and then
that's quite dispersing for sure
and so then it's difficult to proceed
with the same level of enthusiasm